the Republican primary battle between
failed former president Donald Trump and
current Republican governor of Florida
Ron DeSantis hasn't even started yet and
it is already getting towards
allegations of pedophilia I know that it
sounds crazy but failed former president
Donald Trump has gone very very low
suggesting that Ron DeSantis might be a
pedophile in a new attack in which he
accuses DeSantis of grooming young girls
this is really something else Business
Insider has a story about it Trump
shares photos of DeSantis alleging he
partied and drank with high school girls
when he was a teacher Trump re-shared a
20 year old photo of DeSantis that
appears to show imposing with recent
high school graduates the original
poster accused DeSantis of using alcohol
for quote grooming high school girls
Trump is ramping up attacks against the
Florida governor who May challenge him
May challenge him for the 2024 GOP
nomination here is the post Donald Trump
posting yesterday that's not Ron is it
he would never do such a thing and
indeed it is an image
shared by a different truth social user
truth essential with a picture of an
individual that appears to be Ron
DeSantis
three women whose faces are blurred and
the title here is Ron Des sanctimonious
grooming high school girls with alcohol
as a teacher now you don't have to
defend Ron desantis's actions to realize
how ugly this has the potential to get
now there's a few different stories here
one story is if Trump is going this hard
against a guy who isn't even running
against him yet how ugly would an actual
campaign get between DeSantis and Trump
I think the answer is it would get
extraordinarily ugly potentially more
than ugly enough to damage both of them
and help whoever is the Democratic
candidate and that's something I would
be very glad to see secondly there is
this question of hypocrisy because at
the end of the day remember when Donald
Trump ran Miss Teen USA and Miss us say
he said I'll go backstage before a Show
everybody's getting dressed you know no
men anywhere but I'm allowed to go in
because I'm the owner of the pageant so
I'm inspecting it you know they're
standing there with no clothes these
incredible looking women and I get away
with things like that so Trump doesn't
exactly have an unblemished record with
this stuff grab them by the you know
what the allegations by E Gene Carroll
the allegations which were later uh
retracted in the legal sense against
Trump
um and Jeffrey Epstein together
involving a young girl you know there's
all these different things so there's
the hypocrisy angle as well but at this
point it is abundantly clear if DeSantis
runs against trump it may be the ugliest
Republican primary I don't want to say
ever because there have been some ugly
things in history but certainly the
ugliest in the modern media era of the
last four 40 years and it's I don't
think it's good for the country to see
it but at the same time if it hurts both
Trump and DeSantis in the long run it is
actually good for the country DeSantis
or Trump being president next
would be so bad for the country
that anything that damages or reduces
that possibility is actually a good
thing for the country so it's getting
very ugly very quickly and it's only
going to get worse I've had such trouble
finding a great razor where I am not
cutting myself or getting those Nicks on
my skin which are so common with the
cheap disposable razors you have to meet
our sponsor Henson shaving Henson
actually manufactures parts for the
International Space Station and the Mars
rover and they are bringing that exact
same Precision Engineering to the
Shaving experience it hurts when you
shave because blades extend too far and
thus they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below